à peine les moissons terminées qu'il
s'attèle déjà une autre récolte cela
fait 18 ans qu'alexandre jacques mais
cultivent la pomme de terre 20 hectares
à ramasser et les conditions météo cette
saison ne fasse un pas la tâche cette
année avec l'absence de gel l'absence
divers la terre n'a pas bien travaillé
et on le retrouve sur les tapis de des
triages on va passer plus de temps je
pense à l'hectare la campagne
d'arrachage risque d'être un peu allongé
mais sinon
avec les abonnés qui me prendra cet
ouvrage huit personnes le matin 8
l'après-midi pour récolter une
production qui s'annonce abondante mais
ce n'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle car l'an passé les stocks
étaient déjà très important certains ont
même dû jeter données vendre à perte
trop de femmes de terre de quoi tirer
les prix vers le bas malgré les efforts
des quelques 500 producteurs de beauce
pour assurer une excellente qualité
aujourd'hui on vend la pomme de terre 10
centimes le kilo 10 centimes le kilo on
est en dessous des coûts de production
avec tout ce qu'on peut apporter on est
en dessous donc de notre coup et on le
retrouve au supermarché du coin à 1 euro
20 1 euros 50 le kilo la halle en a
beaucoup de mal et l'embargo de la
russie sur les fruits et légumes
n'arrange rien 3 % de la production de
pommes de terre y est normalement
exporter les syndicats de producteurs on
appelle donc aux pouvoirs publics pour
assurer la pérennité de l'activité